today on the matt welsh show one of the
most famous and influential youtube
stars on the planet
is allegedly a sex predator who preys on
young boys
not a huge surprise but it does raise a
question do you know what your kids are
doing online
and who they're being influenced by also
five headlines including joe biden's gun
control push
another shocking twist in an alleged
hate crime case
and a republican legislator sparks
controversy by comparing abortion to
slavery
but is he right well yes he is i'll
explain why plus our daily cancellation
reading the comments and much more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know when running a business hr
issues are the thing that can really
kill you i hear this from business
owners all the time
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations
and on top of that hr managers manager
salaries are certainly not cheap
an average of 70 000 a year so you're
paying a lot
it's very really complicated and so if
you're a business owner you're probably
looking for a solution to this problem
thankfully bambi has that solution bambi
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small businesses to
solve this problem
you get a dedicated hr manager you can
craft hr policy and maintain your
compliance all for just 99
a month with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat
month to month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time
and they make it really easy on you that
way you didn't start your business just
so you could spend all of your time on
hr
compliance issues i assume that's not
the case anyway
you can let bambi help and get your free
hr audit today you got nothing to lose
with the hr audit go to bambi.com
walsh right now to schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com
wall spelled b-a-m-b-e-e dot com slash
walsh since the advent of modern media
you know it's been a challenge for
parents to keep track
of the celebrities and public figures
who are influencing their children i was
a kid in the 90s and it wasn't easy for
our parents
but at least back then an adult who
wanted to
know what the kids are into these days
always knew basically where to look all
they had to do was turn on mtv
or a handful of other cable channels and
they could get a view of pop culture
basically in its entirety they may not
have liked what they found
but i know that my dad certainly didn't
but what they found on tv was
pretty much all there was right as far
as pop culture goes for the most part
they didn't have to worry that there was
more
weirder and darker stuff lurking out
there somewhere in the shadows
the situation is very different now
pop culture is more ubiquitous but also
more spread out
more obscure harder for a parent to get
a handle on
and kids spend much more of their time
much more of their time
absorbed in it like pretty much every
second of their day
in many cases absorbed in it they may
still watch a little bit of traditional
tv or maybe not probably not
but most of their time certainly is
spent online and in every sphere where
they go
youtube tick tock instagram etc etc etc
including
websites that i probably don't even know
about there are these celebrity-like
figures who now just go by the title
influencer because
literally their only job is to influence
the audience
that's kids today they live in a world
run by content creators
and influencers and think about those
titles the ambiguity
of those titles is the point because it
doesn't matter what the content is the
point simply is to
make content any content and influence
it's not like the influence is a
byproduct of the music they're making or
the art they're producing now there
still
are singers and other artists who are
also influencing but for people who are
just influenced that's all they do
nothing else
they don't create anything they don't do
anything they simply their only job is
to influence and a lot of times they're
influencing your kid
now influence to what end in what
direction
well that often depends on the corporate
sponsors backing these people
the challenge for parents is that these
influencers rise to prominence quickly
seemingly out of nowhere sometimes
falling out of favor as rapidly as they
rose into it
like like sort of like quarks popping in
and out of existence
for parents it's like an infinite game
of whack-a-mole the result is that
if your child spends a lot of time
online there are going to be influencers
influencing them
that you haven't even heard of despite
the fact that they're massively popular
wealthy and backed by the biggest brands
in the world
a kid in the 60s had you know the
beatles a kid today has a million
different versions of the beatles in a
million different places
and all of them have direct sustained
and sometimes personal access to him
so that's all a long preamble to bring
up the name james charles
i've mentioned him on the show before i
mentioned him again yesterday on twitter
for a reason that i'll explain in just a
moment but to prove my point
a large number of my followers many of
whom are older
when i say older i mean like my age told
me that they had never heard of the guy
and had no idea why i would bring up
such an obscure irrelevant figure
well james charles is a youtube and
instagram instagram influencer
he has 25 million subscribers on youtube
25 million think about that
27 million instagram followers he's also
been sponsored by or worked with a
number of
major multi-million dollar brands
starting with cover girl back in 2016
charles is specifically
a beauty influencer he models makeup
and as we're told where we were told
with great fanfare a few years ago
he was the first male cover girl in
history
which was supposed to be a big deal he's
also allegedly a sex predator
charles who is a 21 year old man has
been repeatedly accused of sexting
sending new pictures to and trying to
solicit sex from a series of underage
boys
the accusations have come from boys as
young as 14.
now charles in an apology video posted
to youtube a few days ago
confessed actually to messaging a couple
of um a couple of these
alleged victims in this case a couple of
16 year old boys by far not the only
boys to have accused him
but he confessed to having messaged them
but he also said that he didn't know
their age and after some self-reflection
and
quote research he decided that he
shouldn't be involved with them
let's listen to that within the past
couple of weeks two different people
both under the age of 18 have recently
come forward saying that they had
inappropriate messages with me on social
media
uh one of them being from last year and
one of them being from more recent
in both of these cases i added these
people on snapchat asked how old they
were right away
was told that they were 18 believe them
engaged in a flirty conversation and
then later on
found that they were actually 16. upon
finding out i was
immediately embarrassed and blocked both
people later on when i saw them making
videos about it and those videos going
viral
my immediate reaction completely
honestly was
to be really really upset i wanted to
get on camera and film another no more
lies video where i gather all my
receipts and all my screenshots
and try to tell my side of the story and
then just move on from the situation
and now looking back that was so stupid
because
as i did more research on these topics
and self-reflected
i realized that the receipts and the
screenshots and the sys
and the specific details of the
interaction really don't matter
because i stopped he did some research
he had to do some research to find out
about
you know whether he should be messaging
underage boys i guess
i don't know now as i said that's those
are only
two of the accusations and not even the
most serious ones
in that same video he also justified his
actions on the basis that he's lonely
and desperate
in the past he's admitted publicly that
he's not attracted to older guys
although he did say you know he likes
him younger but he said only down to 18
he said during an appearance on the
impulsive podcast another really popular
thing that your kid probably listens to
and you may not have heard of
he seemingly admitted that that he has
on multiple occasions at least attempted
to fly high school boys out to meet him
let's listen to that talk to guys that
live in different states and stuff and
i'm like hey like why don't you come
visit like well i can't afford a plane
ticket
that's like okay well i can so like get
on the plane and like well i just don't
really feel comfortable with that but
like i love you and i really want to be
together
and i'm like well we can't be together
because you can't afford a plane ticket
you're probably
still in either high school or college
like a senior in high school or in
college right so
either you accept the flight and realize
that like this is what i'm bringing to
the relationship so we can spend time
together if you actually care about me
or we literally never meet because you
can't afford it
that's the closest thing to an admission
of a felony sex crime that you're likely
to ever hear on a podcast at least i
hope
so this is a man multiply accused of
soliciting sex from children who has
come very close to confessing to the
charge on multiple occasions publicly
in front of an audience of millions and
yet he remains on youtube
his videos are still monetized as far as
now he hasn't even been suspended
his corporate backers sponsors
affiliates have almost all remained
silent and he's got a lot of them
there's little media coverage of the
scandal little public outrage
it's not hard to see why charles was
hailed by the left and the media five
years ago when he became the historic
world's first cover boy boy right and
he's a you know he's a he's a
homosexual man celebrated for breaking
gender barriers and so on now
for this man to also be a sex predator
and for the left in the media to be
responsible for putting him in a
position to prey on boys well
that's just untenable they can never
accept that or admit to it
ever especially because people like
like me you know the backwards
old-fashioned types
we took one look at this guy and
immediately said
that he clearly has serious issues
we were labeled bigots for that i mean
the left can never admit
that we were right because then it had
then they'd have to ask
why we were right how could we have been
right
i mean why is it that some of us would
look at james charles
listen to him for five seconds and come
to the conclusion that he has to put up
mildly
issues why is it
uh why is it that those of us who knew
about this guy
and then heard that he's trying to pick
up young boys
why is it that we would respond by
saying well yeah you know no surprise
there
how how did we come to that conclusion
this is a dangerous conversation for the
left and one they don't want to have
they want us to believe it's entirely
healthy and a laudable thing for a man
to reject his masculinity to this extent
those of us who say that it is perhaps a
troubling sign
a sign of something unhealthy
psychologically
are labeled bigots and phobes of various
sorts
we can't we can't be allowed to have
been right that can't be permitted
so they'll just ignore it james charles
will continue
preying on children allegedly he'll
continue being an enormously influential
figure
maybe even influential to your own
children
unless you step in between to protect
your kids
from these predators and degenerates
which you should and i hope you do
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
now we're welcoming uh new sponsors of
the show we're very excited about moiq
look look moyc they've got an
interesting name and a great product on
top of it so you get this is this is
a product you should remember because
moiq delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
wild-caught alaskan salmon directly to
your door
helping family farms become financially
independent outside of big agriculture
so you've got
that benefit but also uh you just got
the meat you got the meat that's coming
to your
to your to your house that you can cook
up and it's very delicious their animals
are raised outdoors their fish swim wild
in the ocean and moink meat is free of
antibiotics hormones sugar and all the
other junk
that you find in pre-packaged in the
meat aisle it doesn't make the taste any
better
and it certainly isn't any isn't any
healthier for you so you could sign up
at moicbox.com
walsh to get a year of ground beef for
free and then uh and you can't beat that
and then you can pick what meats you
want delivered for your first buck
change what you what you get each month
you can cancel any time
moich was founded by an eighth
generation farmer who was featured on
shark tank host kevin o'leary
said that it's the best bacon he's ever
tasted and i can
second that opinion i agree with that
and look when a man tells you that's the
best bacon he's ever had that is
quite a statement so you've got at least
you've got to give this a try right join
the
movement today go to moicbox.com walsh
right now
listeners to this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one year of the
best ground beef you'll ever taste
but for a limited time so that's spelled
m
o i n k box dot com slash walsh that's
monkbox.com walsh
all right so joe biden
um announced yesterday some
measures that he would be taking for gun
control
and uh you know actually a little bit of
a little bit of a personal tie-in here i
should
i should mention that um i did go out
yesterday and buy a gun myself
i figured it was you know good good time
to do that
especially with all these with with joe
biden in office and uh you know i have
to say
aside from the fact that i had to show
an id
and give lots of personal information
and fill out a questionnaire about my
mental health and
criminal history and wait for the
background check to clear and pay
hundreds of dollars
it was so much easier than voting except
for all of those things
it was so much easier than voting except
for all of the things that made it way
more difficult than voting
it was a lot easier
that was just my experience though um
and and that of course is i'm in
tennessee
you know in many other states it's going
to be uh to getting a gun is
far more difficult than that and you
have to wait a lot more than
than a few minutes for the background
check to clear anyway joe biden
announced executive orders to enact gun
control fox has some details about that
it says an administration official
detailed the actions to reporters on
wednesday among them biden is asking the
justice department
to propose within a month within a month
a rule to stop
quote-unquote ghost guns which are kits
people can buy legally to assemble a
functioning firearm that does not have a
serial number
biden is also asking the doj to propose
within 60 days
yeah by the way i'm sure that your
average criminal looking to commit a
crime
is taking the time to assemble their own
gun right i'm sure that's what's
happening
in most cases biden is also asking the
doj to propose within 60 days a rule
on braces used for handguns which make
them more accurate to propose action on
community violence intervention
to publish suggestions for red flag
legislation and is asking his
administration to issue a report on gun
trafficking
so those are all the things that he's
thinking of doing
and a lot of it is purposefully vague
like there's more to come so we're not
we're not told everything that's going
to happen here and that's part of the
point
here is joe biden announcing this and
talking specifically about the
constitutional concerns
and then promptly dismissing all of
those concerns let's listen
today we're taking steps to confront not
just the gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis
nothing nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake from what we're talking about
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution is absolute
you can't yell crowd you can't yell fire
in a crowded movie theater we call the
freedom of speech
from the very beginning you couldn't own
any weapon you wanted to own
from the very beginning the second
amendment existed certain people weren't
allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things were recommended
are contrary to the constitution gun
violence
in this country is an epidemic let me
say it again
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic and it's an international
embarrassment
you can't yell crowd in a fired movie
theater
he actually trotted out that old thing
yeah you have to remember when you're
hearing a democrat talk about the
constitution
they are very very selective in
the way that they uh choose to interpret
it and
which amendments are absolute and which
aren't
these are simply not serious people when
it comes to constitutional
interpretation or anything else
keep in mind that these are the same
people joe biden among them
who would tell you and have told you and
insisted upon this for the last four
decades that uh
that that the constitution
guarantees the right to abortion
even though abortion is not mentioned in
the constitution
or hinted at or referenced or or
there's there's no language at all in
the constitution
that comes anywhere close to abortion
and yet they'll say the constitution
absolutely guarantees a right to
abortion
and they they they hinge that that right
on the constitutional right to privacy
even though that's also not in the
constitution
the word privacy doesn't appear
so they have located the right to
abortion
um which does not exist in the
constitution in the right to privacy
which also does not exist
and yet they can do all of that fancy
footwork and all those maneuvers
and they can pull out their decoder pen
and you know they're looking at the
invisible
ink and they're putting things together
and they're they're approaching it like
a word search they're circling cert oh
there's an a here look a b
o r you see it's all coming together
they can do that
for abortion and yet somehow the second
amendment
which is perhaps the clearest amendment
uh
in the entire document that doesn't
guarantee the right to bear arms
with that all of a sudden now they're
saying well what's the original intent
and
now you care about original intent what
do you think the founding fathers
originally intended to
codify uh the right to kill your your
baby in the womb
was that their original intent
uh joe biden also makes a series of just
straight up false claims
like we always get one of them of course
being this claim i don't think he says
it here he probably
he might have but uh one of them of
course the claim about it's harder to
get a gun than vote
totally false here's a false claim that
he said this time um
about uh how easy it is allegedly to get
a gun at a gun show let's listen
these bills one require background
checks for anyone purchasing a gun
at a gun show or an online sale
most people don't know you walk into a
store and you buy a gun you have a
background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
most people don't know that because it's
not true you know
there's a lot of things that that most
people don't know most most people don't
know
that uh cows can fly to the moon a cow
can fly to the moon
most people don't know that
when you make up facts you could always
make a fact that people don't know it's
a lot of fun actually
no that's not that's uh not true at all
i wish it were that'd be a lot of fun
i wish i could just walk into a gun show
get any gun i want
maybe they hand you an ar-15 walking in
the door for free
you know or it's like a when i used to
go to birthday parties as a kid they'd
give you these party bags on the way out
the door
you know because all the kids had to get
now we were the participation trophy
generation so all the kids had to get
gifts at a birthday party otherwise it
wouldn't be fair anyway i wish there was
a
like a gift bag when you leave the gun
show got an ar-15 in there
you know that would be fun but that's
not how it works
uh it's not true at all and jen saki was
asked about this like 30 minutes later
about this thing you just heard joe
biden say that right
and here's jen saki denying that joe
biden said the thing that we all just
heard him say
president said a moment ago quote you go
to a gun show
you can buy whatever you want no
background check
is there a special exemption in federal
law that he was referring to or just
do fla dealers not have to do background
checks when they're
at a gun show all right are you asking
me if he was referring no
it's okay were you asking me if he was
referring to like a specific
circumstance or i'm sorry just tell me a
little bit more about your question
i mean is it the president's belief that
you do not have to undergo a background
check
when you are at a gun show no it's not
his belief he believes that
gun that background check should be
universal right he says
no background check well we know what
his position is right so let me
reiterate that which is that
gut background checks or something that
should be universal they're supported by
more than 80 percent of the public he
supported legislation
advocated for that um and advocated
against loopholes as well so that's his
position and i appreciate you asking for
the clarification
you can always tell when jenn soccer's
about to lie because her tell
is um that she acts confused by a really
basic
straightforward question that's when you
know she's geared because her
she's trying to think of what the lie is
going to be and she's buying a little
bit of time i don't blame her
it is a tough job i would think um
and why a person with a soul and
integrity probably should shouldn't
accept it
to to be a white house spokesperson and
you know you have to get up there and
lie
every single day so this is her tell she
acts like she's confused
so she's asked uh well the president
biden just
said that you need a background you
don't need a background check at a gun
show
is that true what do you mean i i don't
understand your question
could you rephrase it i'm i'm trying to
understand i really want to understand i
just don't understand that question you
just asked
and then she says that no he doesn't
believe that so he lied then
she bought herself time to tell her lie
and it wasn't even a very good one
because what she said is no
uh but the president doesn't believe
that oh he doesn't believe what he said
huh what's what do we call that when you
say something
that you don't believe um what's that
it's a lie
right okay well thanks for clarifying
that jen
all right number two there were reports
speaking of lies reports last week about
racist graffiti
the good old racist graffiti gambit um
racist graffiti found around campus at a
college called
albion college in michigan the graffiti
said
here's what the graffiti said um kkk
white power die n-words
please and um
we do exist kkk
and then there was a star of david with
the number 666 written across it i guess
supposed to be an anti-semitic thing now
this was a big deal locally got a lot of
attention
the students protested we got some
footage of that there
pretty long line of them this is a small
college it looks like they all came out
look at them all
all marching they all came out to march
against racism on campus
and then what is it i don't i don't have
to tell you what happens next do i
you already know you heard racist
graffiti and if you
if you've been paying attention at all
over the last 10 years you know exactly
where this is headed
it was a hoax it was a black student
that wrote the graffiti
you know even without the the history
even without knowing the history you
probably would have already guessed that
this is a hoax
because this just isn't kkk white power
who do you think is is going to
sincerely write that
even if it was a an actual white racist
like why would they write that
but as we've covered many times you know
people who want to invent
hate crimes and turn themselves into a
victim
they have they have a lot of trouble
doing it persuasively and convincingly
because they really have not encountered
a lot of racism from white people so
they don't even know what that would be
like they
you know if if if racism from white
people was common in this country number
one
you wouldn't have to invent it you
wouldn't have to make it up
and number two if you did make it up you
would have encountered it so often
that you should be able to make it up
and impersonate it convincingly
but this is obviously someone who has
never encountered a white racist
in his entire life he has no idea what a
right white racist would say
which is good by the way he's never
encountered one that's a great thing we
should celebrate that
so instead he bases it off of like
movies that he saw in tv shows and stuff
that's one way that you know that it's a
hoax and the other way you know it's a
hoax is that
as far as i can remember and correct me
if i'm wrong
at least say this i cannot think in the
last 20 years i cannot think of a single
case
where so-called racist graffiti or a
racist note
left on a receipt or left on someone's
car windshield or slipped under their
door
turned out to be sincere every single
case that i can think of they were all
hoaxes has there been
even one real case i'm assuming
just a law of averages there have to
have been right the last 20 years i have
to
have been at least a couple
of these racist graffiti cases that was
actually done by a white person
maybe anyway mlive has the report says
albion college in the albion department
of public safety says that a student is
responsible for racist graffiti found in
a dorm
last weekend albion police brought the
21 year old black male in for
questioning on april 6th
the student admitted to creating most of
the graffiti and video evidence from
albion's
campus safety department confirms the
statements made by the student
so i i take it from that that he was on
uh security camera footage they said
video evidence confirms it so
i'm assuming that he that probably he
was right in front
of a security camera scrolling this
thing
when it comes to hate crime hoaxes
they're really not sending their best
um but here's the response to this from
albion college
and i could be pronouncing the name of
the college wrong never heard of them
before now but here's what they tweeted
this is this they put they put this out
i think was yesterday this is after it
was already known who was responsible
for this and this is their tweet okay
they said earlier today we identified
the individual responsible for the
racist and anti-semitic graffiti in
mitchell towers
the student who is acting alone
acknowledged our responsibility for
these act for these incidents
they have been immediately removed from
campus and placed on temporary
suspension while we conduct a full
investigation as part of our student
judicial process
but we know the acts of racism that have
occurred this week are not about one
particular person or one particular
incident
we know that there's a significant
history of racial pain and trauma on
campus
and we're taking action to repair our
community we will change and heal
together as a community because we are
committed to doing
the work right now we encourage all
members of our community to listen
respond and care for one another
and lean on the faculty staff community
members who have been gathering today to
make sure we're supporting you
we have your back okay aside from the
normal tripe about
we'll do the work we're committed
the phrase do the work has become to me
as grading and annoying as the phrase
lived experience
and they're always said by the usually
in the same sentence
um by the the the same sorts of people
i'm surprised lived experience didn't
appear in this statement here
we'll do the work to understand your
lived experience
but do you notice so we got to do the
work we got the buzzwords and everything
you notice what's missing from this
statement
they never say it was a hoax they never
say that it was a black student who did
it
in fact they intentionally give the
impression
that it was a white student they don't
say that but they tie all this into
historic racism
racial trauma so on and so forth
they're clearly trying to give the
impression without saying it that
the graffiti really was done by a white
racist
that's the way the school has decided to
handle it
and um if that doesn't work then they
will
um at least try to disperse the blame
[Music]
you know it's we're not going to blame
this one individual uh we're going to
blame the institutions
this this is not this is not about one
particular person
it's about a history of racial pain no
it is definitely about one particular
person it's about the guy who did it
a guy who they say is kicked off a
campus that's good he should also be
charged with a crime
you know a hate crime hoax
is a hate crime i'm not a fan of the
hate crime
designation at all i don't think it
should exist but as long as it does it
should be used equally and in a way
that's
at least sort of coherent and what that
means is that a hate crime hoax should
be considered a hate crime
it is a hate crime against the group of
people that you're trying to frame
that's what it's a hate crime against so
a black student
putting that graffiti up pretending that
a white racist did it that is a hate
crime against white
students he is trying to inflame
hatred towards the white students
and guilt by association is trying to um
to you know uh
defame them as as racist
that's the way we should that's why
these things should be handled all right
um next year we have a report here from
kfor
in oklahoma local news affiliate there
over the controversy surrounding a
republican legislator who
while arguing in favor of pro-life
legislation compared abortion to slavery
and we were
this is a big controversy we're supposed
to be upset about this let's listen to
the news report
representative jim olsen was introducing
his bill to the house public health
committee
when he made these comments that
immediately sparked outrage from some of
his
fellow house members
what was going through my head was shock
and appalled
a controversial comparison made in a
debate over an abortion bill
republican representative jim olson
introducing his bill that would make
performing an abortion a felony
in his argument comparing the fight to
abolish abortion
to a long push to abolish slavery this
is
absolutely worth doing even if it takes
a long time
but that message was a miss for some in
the room saving the lives of an unborn
child is more important than saving the
lives of slaves
none of us would like to be a slave
if i had my choice i guess i'd be a
slave at least the slave has
his life later representative olson
doubling down
saying it's in no way an endorsement of
slavery
in the context of history in general i
did compare one evil to another
and very frankly i make no apology for
it
that's triggering that's traumatizing
that's
hurtful oh shut up it's uh you were
traumatized were you
by someone making a point rhetorically
you're you were traumatized by that
you're suffering trump you have to go to
therapy now that's trauma
okay trauma is like someone survives a
plane crash okay
trauma is someone who is sexually abused
as a child
that's trauma trauma is not a guy made a
point you disagreed with
this jim olsen got to know anything
about him but based on that alone
uh i like him and
the suggestion that he was defending
slavery but what he he was
his that was exactly the opposite point
he was trying to make he's trying to
make a point about how evil
abortion is by comparing it to slavery
now you could disagree but to suggest
that he was what
what was the phrase that he was
defending slavery or justifying it what
that's exactly the opposite of what he
was saying
and in fact as it happens and i've made
this point myself many times
um there is a similarity here
there's a similarity because what you
find throughout history
is that um and and this is true today
and it goes going all the way back and
this has always been the case in human
society unfortunately
that there are always groups of people
who are pointing to other groups of
people and saying that those people
aren't people okay throughout history
you always have that
you have some people trying to de-person
other people
and this comes in various different
forms
um and leads to it always leads to
atrocity and death
and oppression and horrible horrible
things and what you find is that and
this is a really important point
that the people who are doing this who
are doing the de-personing they always
make
the same kinds of arguments always
it never changes for thousands of years
it has hardly changed
now i've i've i this is something i go
through in a lot of my speeches but i'll
go through it here
just to make that point as the point's
been raised um in fact i was giving a
speech
right to life in uh here in nashville in
tennessee a couple days ago and
i went through this same thing so let's
go through it okay just just to
make to make the point um
every pro every pro-abortion argument
has
mirrors our arguments pro-slavery
arguments from the 19th century and
let's let's go through them
there's the argument from ownership this
slave slash baby is my property slash
body you can't
tell me what to do with it there's the
argument from privacy no one is forcing
you to have slave slash abortions mind
your own business
there's the argument from superseding
rights my property slash body autonomy
rights come before the rights of a slave
fetus there's the argument from
inevitability
slavery abortion has been around for
thousands of years it's never going away
we might as well the safe and legal
system in place for it
there's the argument from pseudoscience
slave slash fetuses aren't really people
they aren't
like us look at them they're physically
different therefore we are human and
they are not
there's the argument from socioeconomics
if slavery slash abortion ends most of
these slave slash babies will end up on
the street without a job
there's the argument from the courts
this is a big one slavery slash abortion
has been vindicated by the supreme court
it's settled law
there's the argument from faux
compassion slavery abortion is in the
best interest of the african slash
babies the world can be a cruel place
it's best to protect them
by keeping them in slave slash killing
them then there's the argument from the
assumed hypocrisy of the other side
you say you want to end slavery slash
abortion but you don't want to live with
free black slash adopt unwanted babies
yourself
that's only a partial list every single
one directly
correlates with arguments made today for
abortion
and uh finally we have time for this
yeah
we'll make time because we got to make
time for this um you know i love playing
the tic tac videos for you
and uh here's here's a good one no
introduction needed here's another
tick-tock woman
screaming in her car always fun let's
watch so
done with this world i'm so tired of it
i'm so
tired of this selfish idiotic behavior i
have
one two i have three
inhalers three and i'm glad to carry
this
an iron lung with me anywhere i go just
in case if things don't work
and you have the nerve to tell me that
you have a doctor's note not to wear
this
if any doctor gave you that it's because
you're that weak you can't wear a piece
of cloth
you're a selfish and if your husband
does that too in public
i hope you both catch coven i hope you
both understand how serious this is
my four-year-old needs me my disabled
husband who broke his spine in 2016
needs me i'm the only one doing anything
in my house
because they name me and yourself is
trying to take me away from them
okay darling um first of all if you have
trouble breathing
calm down stop screaming this is not
this isn't this is not helping your
asthma i tell you that much
um second of all mind your own business
my body my choice right remember one of
the pro-abortion arguments
except it actually like really applies
here whereas it doesn't apply for
abortion because
again as we talked about i've talked
about many times abortion is the
the direct killing of another person is
the direct destruction of another
person's body
not wearing a mask is not the direct
destruction of another person's body
by not wearing a mask you are not
intentionally and directly killing
another person you're not
anyone who says you are is insane a
lunatic and should be disregarded
so in this case i'll say yeah my body my
choice simple as that i don't want to
wear it so i'm not going to
um but i do also have to say you know
with all due respect
um she says that she's the only one
doing anything for her health and she's
trying to look out for
well the number one risk factor
for covid yeah asthma is not not good
but
really number one risk factor is obesity
and uh we're a year into this thing and
you say that you care
you're taking this so seriously right
you're taking it so seriously
and uh your health is so important to
you but you haven't
you're still very overweight and so
you're you're in a
high risk category if you were taking
your health is that that seriously you'd
be taking care of that
because that's something that you can do
yourself
can't blame anyone else for that that is
something you can do
um and if you did it would lower your
covet risk
substantially so if you're not even
doing that then i guess i question how
seriously you're really taking it
all right let's move on to quickly
reading a few of these comments here
anna says thanks for talking about aging
i'm tired of this youth-obsessed society
how society pretends no one ages and if
they do there's something wrong with
them
yeah well and that as we talked about
yesterday it's
[Music]
partially a symptom of our fear of death
we we
probably live in one of the most deaf
phobic societies in human history
human beings have always been afraid of
death but we are so
uh pardon the phrase dead set on denying
it
not thinking about it avoiding it
to an extent to an extent that i think
sets us apart from from many other human
societies in history
and that's it's a symptom of that that's
also one of the reasons why and i've
never understood this
why asking somebody their age is like
embarrassing you're not supposed to ask
that question
that is that is a social convention that
i think is so ridiculous
and i reject it and i don't i ask people
their age all the time i don't care
how old or young they seem to be
because sometimes it could be something
you're curious about it kind of it
relates to the conversation you're
having
i have no problem say how old are you
and yeah oftentimes people will look at
you like you just ask
them how much money they have in their
bank account
or you know if they have herpes or
something like they
they look at you like you've just asked
this incredibly personal
it's not who cares it's your age it's
simply how long you've been on earth
why is that a really personal
embarrassing detail
i i don't get it if you've been around a
long time that's good you should be
proud of that
it's not embarrassing so what if you're
52 you're embarrassed that you've been
it's embarrassing that you've been on
earth for 52 years
you would rather that you've only been
on earth for 22
why if anything it's embarrassing to be
younger because it means you have less
experience
less wisdom less credibility in a lot of
areas
i like getting old i can't wait to be
older
um once i get to like 70 you know that's
gonna be that's really i've been i've
been 70 years old really spiritually my
whole life and so when i get to 70
that's when i will know that i'm home
um
let's see t smith says hey matt just
listen to your rumination on the meaning
of life for non-religious people whereas
mine was
reminded of a segment a while back when
you critiqued sam harris's position on
free will
are you up on sam's philosophy relating
to the meaning of life from his waking
up podcast
i'd be curious to hear your thoughts i'm
not sure exactly what
what you're referring to i did hear a
clip of his a while ago that someone
sent me that i thought was interesting
where he talks about the reality of
death
and uh you know how how to live in spite
of the fact that we're going to die and
he's
he's approaching this as an atheist i
think he did his
he does as good a job as an atheist can
do in dealing with that subject
and basically basically explaining how
you can live
with joy and purpose even knowing from
the atheist perspective that you're soon
going to be dead and erased from
existence
and everyone's going to forget about you
and you will just evaporate into the
ether and nothing you ever did will
matter
like even knowing that how do you live
with joy and purpose sam
harris i've heard him address that a few
times he does as good a job as you could
possibly do
with that but that's still not very good
because you can't get around on the
atheist worldview
the inherent meaningless of life you
can't get around it
um and finally tristan says would i be
wrong in thinking that as a species we
are sick and insane no you would not
in fact that's that's a
go from the atheist worldview to the
christian worldview that's a that is
one of the fundamental facets of the
christian worldview that we are
a sick uh people in need of healing
i've been telling you for for weeks now
about our friends at
constitutioncoach.com and the great
experience that i had
taking their constitutional defense
course i mean it's all about equipping
you with that intellectual ammunition to
understand the
the constitution be able to to defend it
and defend yourself both rhetorically
and physically you get an amazing
combination of intellectual ammunition
and live classes with rick green
america's constitution coach and then
you also get the physical training
at the premier firearms training
facility in the nation get this all in
the same course
uh you get to join hundreds of other
patriots from across the nation this
really is a
it's a one-of-a-kind opportunity it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
it's not the kind of thing that you do
every day and you got to take advantage
of this don't just get a gun you got to
learn how to carry with confidence and
get the training you need to defend your
family a lot of people
now are running out and buying guns
exercising their second amendment rights
which is great
but learn how to use it also go to
constitutioncoach.com with all the
instability in the u.s these days
this training is more important than
it's ever been rick and the constitution
coach team have another class on april
25th it is filling up very very fast
so go to constitutioncoach.com and sign
up again that's constitutioncoach.com
and you know it's an exciting time of
the week again our own candace owens
will be live streaming her new talk show
candace
at 9 p.m eastern pm central tonight's
episode candace's cancel corner will
feature clay travis sports commentator
and founder of outkick sports
he's the host of outkick the coverage on
fox sports radio out kick the show
live stream and wins and losses podcast
and i heart clay has been cancelled from
cnn and
espn for his upfront and sometimes in
your face commentary so he's going to
have
a lot to say with candace you could tune
in to watch their hilarious discussion
tonight at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
uh only on dailywire.com and get 25 off
with a new membership with code
candace now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to a website called openly
now the bill they build themselves as an
impartial in
quote impartial lgbt plus news
organization now my first issue here off
the bat is that they've
left off the queue i'm not sure why that
is
this has been a really bad year for the
letter q i think but in any case openly
published a lengthy thread which went
viral
and it's supposed to demonstrate the
validity of quote non-binary identities
by showing that cultures across the
world have their own versions of
non-binary or trans people
now many on the left think they
succeeded now i think they succeeded too
it's just that
they succeeded in proving my point not
their own point
so let's take a look at the threat this
is what they said quote
the gender binaries of male and female
aren't as universal as you think from
samoa to albania
here are eight cultures throughout
history showing that the concept of
non-binary gender is far from new
now we'll stop right there for a second
this is a tactic that the left likes to
trot out from time to time
usually in an effort to normalize one of
their preferred lifestyles
but this strategy creates some problems
for the people who use it
the problem is that the look other
cultures in the world agree with me
knife cuts both ways there are many
societies across the globe still today
and certainly throughout history that
for example
considered homosexuality to be sinful in
many cultures there are still very
traditional ideas about the role of
women there are plenty of cultures where
fathers decide
who their daughters marry and so on if
we're meant to embrace gender fluidity
because other cultures allegedly
practice it
then should we also revert back to
traditional marriage and patriarchal
family structures on the same basis
oh no of course not no we're supposed to
celebrate and embrace
other cultures based entirely on how
those cultures conform to western
liberal ideas
that's what the left thinks i don't know
about you but that sounds a little
what's the word they like to use um
colonialist
to me now let's look at the examples
they provide
we'll go through some of these um two
spirits
north america identifying with
masculinity and femininity indigenous
north
north american two-spirit people are
often said to contain both male and
female spirits
they're often revealed in their
communities seen as a channel between
the physical and the spiritual
then we go to samoa identifying as a
separate gender
fa faffins i'm going to mispronounce a
lot of stuff when i read this but just
just go with me farfanin's roles in
society moves fluidly between the
traditional male and female
while they're assigned male at birth
samoa also recognizes
fatima an equally fluid gender for those
assigned
female at birth and we go to south asia
the hedras
they say the centuries-old third gender
associated with sacred powers
usually refers to those assigned male at
birth but don't identify as such
in 2014 india legally recognized hidraz
as a third gender after they were
criminalized by the british in 1871.
then we have the sworn virgins in
albania in this dying practice women
take on the social identity of a man for
life while taking a vow of chastity
by taking on this identity they're
elevated to the status of a man
entitled to the rights and privileges of
the patriarchy that we go to the metis
in nepal officially recognized as a
third gender in nepal in 2017 or rather
2007
metis have a long history in the
himalayan region assigned male at birth
they assume a traditional feminine
appearance
nepal said a global precedent with a
third gender category on official
documents
and finally the toms in thailand one of
the dozens or more common gender
identities in thailand
toms are women who adopt masculine
mannerisms and style
while using male speech patterns toms
are often attracted to
ds women who follow traditional thai
gender norms
okay let's run through a few issues here
first of all we're just assuming for the
sake of argument that all of the
information provided here is actually
correct
and that is a wild assumption and
probably a bad one
but that has to be our starting point
for the sake of argument
just remember to apply a healthy portion
of salt to everything that you just
heard
i don't even know if all that is true
for all i know it's all false
for example i do know that the
two-spirit term uh the first thing they
mentioned for native americans
that term dates back to 1990. lgbt
activists came up with it about 30 years
ago it's not some ancient idea
stretching back into the distant past
they just came up with this
i suspect if i researched all of these
other examples i would find similar
caveats but again for the sake of
argument
let's pretend that all of the
information in the thread is correct and
not at all misleading
on that assumption it actually defeats
the very point that it's supposed to
make
why well first of all in some of these
cases the supposedly non-binary
identification is religious in nature
we're told about the third gender people
in south asia who are believed to have
sacred powers
but but they don't really have sacred
powers of course
this is obviously an incorrect belief
about the way the world works
it's a doctrinal religiously based
belief
some might call it superstitious now
there's nothing wrong with religious
beliefs
uh in principle i have my own religious
beliefs though it is interesting that
leftists will laugh
at christian doctrine while asking us to
take seriously the belief in
mystical third gendered people with
sacred powers
this is not a comparison that works in
the left's favor though ironically i
think
it's pretty good comparison you know
works in my favor i think it's i think
it's a it actually is a pretty good
comparison
but not for the reasons that they think
yes it's true
that the left's theories on gender are
really religious
more than anything they the left i mean
they see gender as this mystical
supernatural thing
and that's how they come up with the
concept of women being trapped in male
bodies and so forth
if they would just come out and admit
this you know if they would admit it and
say that this is their religion
then i would say fine you're entitled to
your religious beliefs but don't try to
force it on me and keep it out of the
schools
but they won't they won't admit that
it's a religious belief even as in this
case
they themselves compare it to the
religious beliefs of other cultures
so that's one problem second finally
notice something else about all these
examples in these other cultures
they may have men who take on a feminine
appearance or women who take on a
masculine appearance
but they don't think that the men
actually are women
or the women actually are men the toms
in thailand
are women with a masculine style we used
to have that here too they were called
tomboys
but in order to be a tom or tomboy you
have to be a woman
with a masculine style the fact that you
are a woman is an essential ingredient
it's what makes you that
in our culture we're now supposed to
believe that the women with masculine
styles
are actually in reality literally men
which means that they aren't women with
masculine styles at all but just men
with regular style
the very thing that makes them different
and supposedly special
is removed by saying that they are the
thing that they're
dressing up as this is the difference
between our culture and every other one
on the list in every case
there are people of one sex in these
other cultures there are people of one
sex who for one reason or another
another dress up as or act as members of
the opposite sex
but nobody thinks that they actually are
members of the opposite sex
the whole point is that they aren't but
are acting like it
that is completely different from what
we do here
now all of this highlights
all it really highlights is that in fact
the modern western idea of gender
is entirely unprecedented
it is a completely new unheard of thing
in the world
the idea that a man can actually become
a woman not simply act like one
or play the role of one but become one
be
one is new and false
and this line of argument presented by
our friends at openly
only underscores that very fact it makes
precisely the opposite point
that it was trying to make it proves the
argument it was meant to debunk so it is
a very bad
stupid argument for them to present but
i appreciate it
and today it gets them canceled
and that will do it for us today and
this week hope you have a great
weekend i'll talk to you on monday
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin